Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus mal wieder leibhaftig
freue mich ja
ganz gut ja sehr gut Richard sag mal die
Folge letzte Woche ne hat mich noch
lange beschäftigt dich auch ging das
auch so ja so zwei Dinge man kann sich
eigentlich nicht vorstellen dass das
molaregime wirklich gibt und man kann
sich auch nicht vorstellen dass die
Proteste aufhören beides kann man sich
nicht vorstellen ne das ist glaube ich
so so die Situation immer gegenwärtig
hat und ich meine die Hoffnung bleibt ja
ich weiß auch wenn es nicht
wahrscheinlich ist können wir Hoffnung
trotzdem stark dass das ist der Punkt
ich
ich habe neulich einen das war im
Nachgang irgendwie zu unserem Gespräch
habe ich einen Interview mit I will way
gelesen
der
war ein interessanten Gedanken äußert
und bei dem ich echt ins Grübeln
gekommen bin der sagte er weißt du ihr
habt nicht verstanden dass diese
Diktaturen die nehmen sich eure Technik
digitale Technik 10.000 der
hunderttausende Überwachungskameras der
chinesische Staat hat offensichtlich die
Absicht den in wenigen Monaten so weit
zu sein dass du innerhalb von zwei bis
drei Sekunden
jederzeit weist wo jeder deiner 1,3
Milliarden BürgerInnen Bürger gerade ist
und
es gibt dieses dieses Buch von Adrian
Geiges und Stefan Aust über China dem
sie die Szene beschreiben wie ein Mann
während der
corona-maßnahmen in Shanghai glaube ich
war es in der U-Bahn sitzt und sein
Handy aus hat und es besteht der
Verdacht dass dieser Mann in Kontakt mit
jemandem hatte der der Corona infiziert
war und die sagen ihm passt auf
wir versuchen den zu erreichen er hat
sein Handy aus und die merke okay wir
kriegen den nicht der sitzt in der Bahn
und wenn ich später klingelt das Telefon
seines Nachbarn in dieser Mann nicht
kennt und dran ist der Typ von der
Behörde und sagt dem Pass auf sag mal
deinem Nachbarn soll mal bitte ans
Telefon gehen wir müssen hier eine
corona-geschichte überprüfen weil die
gesehen haben wer da reingeht in diese
U-Bahn Überwachungskameras wissen sofort
wer das ist wissen wo der sitzt auch in
der U-Bahn im Waggon und können sofort
auf diese Art und Weise zugreifen und
diese digitalen Werkzeuge die sind so
unvorstellbar mächtig das ist der
feuchte Traum von Diktatoren der da
gerade Wirklichkeit wird
wir haben ja als diese digitalen
Techniken alle kamen und als das
Internet kam und so weiter geschwärmt
arabischer Frühling jetzt können sich
alle austauschen jetzt kriegen sie einen
Blick überall jetzt haben sie all die
Möglichkeiten und da kann sozusagen eine
Gegenöffentlichkeit entstehen gegen
Diktatur richtig wir haben völlig
unterschätzt original das auf der
anderen Seite die das Machtpotenzial
stärker zugenommen hat als auf der
positiven Seite richtig das haben wir
ganz lange nicht gesehen wir können das
Internet als freiheitstechnik gerühmt
werden die digitalen Möglichkeiten als
freiheitstechniken und haben nie gesehen
was auf der anderen Seite passiert und
das kann man noch schön an dem Beispiel
sehen dass sich die Piratenpartei für so
mächtig gehalten hat diese kleine Partei
wir sind die Herren des Internets ja wir
verstehen wie das läuft wir werden an
die die digitale Welt besiedeln mit
unserer Politik und dann kam die
nsa-affäre und dann wurde klar die
spielen in einem Sandkasten also die
haben geglaubt es sich Internet das ist
kritisiert ihre Technologie ja aber sie
waren ja eigentlich nur albern in diesem
Glauben ja tatsächlich gehören diese
Dinge immer den mächtigen ja es war
und das ist das ist das ist eine eine
etwas was da Wirklichkeit geworden ist
ich glaube wir überblicken das wirklich
mal ansatzweise ich habe hast du das
gesehen zu wie David Bowie
dieser Tage ging überall viral selbst
mich hat das erreicht okay David Bowie
der in einem Gespräch wann war das ich
glaube Ende der 90er von einem
Journalisten befragt auf die Frage was
denn dieses Internet ist sagt das ist
etwas das von machen wir uns keine
Vorstellung und der Typ sagt nee das ist
doch einfach nur eine andere ein anderes
Liefersystem für Informationen ja eine
andere Form von Journalismus eigentlich
sozusagen ein anderer Vertriebskanal für
Nachrichten für News ja und David Bowie
sagt das hast du nicht verstanden mein
Freund das ist so als wären Aliens auf
der Erde gelandet irre der hat das in
einer Klarheit gesehen die ich
beeindruckend fand ja also ich glaube ja
tatsächlich dass diese digitale
Revolution unsere ganze Gesellschaft
Karneval also karnevalisieren im Sinne
von ummaskieren
und so weiter
aber nicht eben nicht einfach nur lustig
sondern dass das tatsächlich so ist und
wenn wir heute darüber sprechen dass wir
das Gefühl haben dass unsere westlichen
Demokratien instabiler sind als sie vor
30 40 Jahren und so weiter waren und uns
fragen woran liegt das eigentlich dann
spielt natürlich die digitale Revolution
da eine große Rolle nicht so monokausal
dass das jetzt schlecht und bösen ist
sondern Machtverschiebungen
Akzentverschiebungen und so weiter das
heißt also so die Bausteine aus denen
unsere Demokratie unsere Öffentlichkeit
und so steht die werden alle umgemünzt
ja als richtig ja und für diese neue
ungemünzte Situation
dafür da haben wir keine Mitte bisher
gefunden ja das haben wir irgendwie
nicht richtig im Griff
zum Beispiel dass wir heute Menschen
haben die wahrscheinlich 50% ihres
Lebens Infektionen oder im digitalen
Raum unterwegs sind ja die also in
dieser Gesellschaft abwesende Anwesenden
ja weil sie weil sie gerade in Serien
sind oder irgendwo anders da sind so das
sind ja alles Dinge an die halt nie
jemand gedacht als die parlamentarische
Demokratie erfunden wurde oder die
Volkssouveränität richtig das
hinterlässt aber Wirkungen das verändert
Menschen es war das Ausmaß der
Individualisierung dass ich dadurch
fortgesetzt hat dass jeder sich also in
einem unüberschaubaren Supermarkt von
Lebensweisen sein Segment und seine
Freunde irgendwo raussucht in einer
globalen gemeinsam seine Religion to go
ja genau Spiritualität
Heimwerker des Glaubens geworden sind in
religiösen und nicht religiösen Fragen
und auf alles das sind wir überhaupt
noch nicht vormachen war und ich glaube
vieles von dem was wir jetzt erleben ist
und Zeichen dieser Überforderung ja die
Technik ist einfach schneller als unser
Bewusstsein und es ist schneller als
unsere Anpassungsfähigkeiten ja und
dieses dieses ich glaube es da gibt es
auch ich habe Leuchten ich glaube
Johannes Hepp heißt der Mann in einem
psychoanalystikhaus München der ist ein
tolles Buch gemacht muss ich mir noch
mal in Ruhe ganz so Gemüte führen der
sagt es gab es gab so verschiedene
Stufen von Demütigung ja Kopernikus war
die erste ja ja das sind das sind die
klassischen freudchen freudchen
Demütigung
unser Unterbewusstsein oder Unbewusstes
uns regiert und ich unter Verstand genau
und die vierte neun Programm ja so hat
er das definiert dass unser iPhone mehr
weiß als wir selbst und besser ist als
wir selbst das und das macht was mit uns
der ich deswegen ich habe auch das
Gefühl dass diese diese ganze aufgeregte
Diskussion um die Frage ob Elon Musk
jetzt Twitter übernehmen darf und ob das
die Demokratie gefährdet ja was das
eigentlich mit uns macht das ist genau
Ausdruck dieser uns
ich glaube wenn David Bowie heute leben
würde würde er prognostizieren dass
spätestens seit acht Jahren Elon Musk
die USA regiert ja dass er dann der
Präsident sein manchmal hältst du das
für möglich ich kann das nicht
einschätzen ich habe nicht die geringste
Ahnung ey sagen wir mal so ich halte es
für denkbar
Richard weil wir gerade eingangs über
Iran gesprochen haben und über die Art
und Weise sozusagen was wir für
Instrumentarien was für ein
Instrumentenkasten wir plötzlich zur
Verfügung haben ich wollte mit dir heute
sprechen über zivilen Ungehorsam in
aller Munde Deutschland diskutiert ja
über die Frage was da eigentlich
passiert seit am 23 Oktober
Kartoffelbrei und ein weltberühmtes
Gemälde von Monet der Heuschober
plötzlich eine Einheit bildeten in
Potsdam
wie schaust du da drauf ich sag dir nur
mal ganz kurz mojiplativ wir hatten
schönen Satz dazu gesagt die Art und
Weise also der Klimaforscher ja wie es
jetzt bei der letzten Generation
geschieht was die da machen schreckt
viele Menschen ab und wir werden einen
ambitionierten Klimaschutz nur dann
hinbekommen wenn wir breite Schichten
der Bevölkerung dafür gewinnen auf
bayerisch wir können die Reaktion was
ist schon gehört wir müssen eine Klima
RF verhindern also das ist die
Bandbreite der Reaktionen weil man sagen
muss das Bild ist hinter Glas ne eben
und das macht die Aktion weniger
verbrecherisch aber umso alberner alban
ja das ist ja dann irgendwo so ein
bisschen albern also dieser Gedanke ist
ja ganz grundsätzlich nachvollziehbar
dass man sagt wenn alles zu langsam
geschieht an Maßnahmen gegen den
Klimawandel und so weiter dann muss man
stärker auf sich aufmerksam machen also
bis dahin kann ich folgen
die Art und Weise wie man das macht wie
jetzt hier diese Kartoffelbrei Nummer
und sowas alles die haben halt was
albernes und die haben halt diesen
wahnsinnigen Nachteil dass sie viele
Menschen die nur darauf gewartet haben
ja die Klimabewegung üble Gesinnungen
oder üble Methoden dass die jetzt
dermaßen beschädigt werden und wenn
Alexander Dobrindt man muss ja sagen
sich wirklich nicht entblödet ja da also
von Terrorismus zu sprechen
also die AF war eine Bundle ja von von
gesinnungsfreundinnen die zahlreiche
Menschen umgebracht entführt und
umgebracht haben und das hier zu
vergleichen auf dieser Ebene das ist
absurd bis zum geht nicht mehr aber es
zeigt
ich glaube dass es so bei manchen Leuten
ein großes Bedürfnis gibt dass die dass
man ja nie was in der Hand hatte gegen
die Leute Fridays for future schauen und
die klimaaktivisten weil die hier auf
der guten Seite stehen zu sagen ihr seid
auch nicht alle gute unter euch sind
fürchterliche Verbrecher da gibt es ein
großes Bedürfnis weißt du was mich daran
aufregt ist natürlich kann man sagen das
war hinter Glas aber ich ich weiß aus
gut informierten Kreisen das war
haarscharf der Rahmen war offensichtlich
nicht mehr ganz dicht ja das heißt es
war ganz ganz knapp dass dieses Ding
wirklich ernsthaft beschädigt wird das
hat jemand Hasso Plattner der SAP
Gründer für 111 Millionen gekauft und
nicht nur das der hängt immer so der
kann sich das auch einfach ins
Wohnzimmer hängen und dann sehen wir das
alle nie wieder aber stattdessen stellt
das der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung und
ich sag mal so nach so einer Aktion mit
der sich das zweimal überlegen und ich
möchte gerne weiterhin nicht nur ich
sondern auch meine Kinder und alle
anderen sollen sich diese großartige
Kunst angucken können und das wird dazu
führ dass ich natürlich
museumsverantwortlich in aller Welt
jetzt fragen auch in Madrid ist es ja
auch passiert ja Francisco dekoria und
so dass man dass man sich fragt okay
können wir das noch machen oder oder
riskieren wir das das wirklich
Kulturgeschichte der Menschheit
beschädigt wird es geht einfach nicht
das siehst du auch bei dieser tragischen
Geschichte rund um diese 44 Jahre alte
glaube ich Radfahrerin die in Berlin
jetzt zu Tode gekommen ist das war ja
auch dann sozusagen der wirklich
ernsthafte Hintergrund der dann zur
Frage geführt hat wie weit darf Protest
eigentlich gehen also eine 44-jährige
Frau die unter einen in
Berlin-Wilmersdorf glaube ich war das
unter einen Betonmischer kommt ja und
obwohl unsere selben Zeit finden in
derselben Stadt diese Proteste Stadt es
bildet sich ein Stau ja und obwohl
offensichtlich diese Aktivisten der
sogenannten letzten Generation eine
Rettungsgasse gemacht haben waren die zu
schmal zu der zweite Spezialfahrzeug ja
dass da sozusagen durch kommen sollte
und deswegen sofort sozusagen der der
Zusammenhang okay das ist nicht
durchgekommen weil ihr hier protestiert
habt weil ihr euch angeklebt habt
deswegen ist die Frau gestorben das ist
aber nicht so erwiesen das war
mutmaßlich nicht so sondern ich habe das
bei den Kollegen der Süddeutschen
gelesen und auch anderswo auch die
Kollegen vom Stern die gerade diese
Woche die Titelgeschichte auch zu dem
Thema machen übrigens das interessant
sobald er will Weber tolles Stück dazu
geschrieben
die sagen die Notärztin hat schon vorher
sozusagen auf weitere Maßnahmen und
Anforderungen eigentlich auch von
Rettungsfahrzeugen verzichtet weil ihr
klar war diese Frau der kann sie jetzt
nicht mehr helfen ja und das ist auch
später verstorben sie war da drunter
eingequetscht stiller das heißt also
deswegen so schnell in den in den Wagen
erstmal auch nicht lagern können also
kann ja kein normaler Rettungswagen
gewesen sein genau wie dem im Detail ist
also das ist tragisch wenn es irgendwie
so gewesen sein sollte dass durch diese
Demonstration die Frau gestorben ist wie
gesagt es ist nicht wahrscheinlich aber
vielleicht gibt es ja doch irgendeine
ursichtlichen Zusammenhang jetzt kann
man natürlich sagen das kann ja durch
jeden anderen Verkehrsstau natürlich
auch passieren was ich möchte nicht
wissen wie oft in Deutschland
irgendwelche Rettungswagen irgendwo
nicht durchkommen und zwar völlig
unabhängig ob es sich um Berufsverkehr
handelt oder ob es sich darum handelt
das Kurden für Kurdistan demonstrieren
und ja oder eine antiputin-demo ist oder
was auch immer und was wir hier machen
die Tragik die darin besteht dass diese
Demo diesen Rettungswagen aufgehalten
hat in ein irgendeine Verbindung zu
bringen mit den Zielen der Demonstranten
das sind zwei Dinge die passen nicht
zusammen denn wenn es eine Demo wäre zu
anderen Zwecken dann hätten wir die
Demonstranten vielleicht nicht im
gleichen Maße verurteilt und das ist
sozusagen der Denkfehler das sind zwei
verschiedene Dinge ja also die Frau
starb an den Folgen dieses Unfalls und
nicht an den Folgen der Blockade kann
man so klar und deutlich sagen natürlich
ist es trotzdem das ist ja dass das mor
für die lämmerig hat und deswegen finde
ich den den Fall auch so interessant es
sind natürlich ein Unterschied ob ein
ein Rettungswagen im Berufsverkehr
sozusagen nicht durchkommt Menschen auf
dem Weg zur Arbeit Menschen auf dem Weg
zu ihrer Existenzsicherung ja oder ob
ein Rettungswagen oder in dem Fall ein
Spezialfahrzeug nicht durchkommt weil
irgendjemand demonstriert demonstriert
und die und die Straße blockiert sich
festklebt sozusagen und das ja dann in
gewisser Weise weil du ja weißt in dem
Moment wo du dich hier fest klebst dann
kannst du nicht mehr ganz schnell
einfach mal die Straße Räumen das
funktioniert überhaupt nicht also es
könnte am besten nimmt man es dann
billigend den Kauf also was haben sie
nicht darüber nachgedacht da haben die
nicht drüber nachgedacht und das kann
sein dass eine Folge dessen ist das
Festkleben nicht mehr erlaubt ist
das könnte ja passieren also man könnte
sagen demonstrieren könnte aber ihr
könnt euch nicht mehr festkleben oder so
oder anketten also das ist dann
sozusagen Einschränkungen generell bei
Demonstration gibt was man nicht machen
darf aus um Unfälle zu vermeiden aber
ich sehe von meinem inneren Auge nicht
in Deutschland aber in anderen Ländern
ja da könnte man wunderbar könnte man im
Iran jetzt sagen ihr dürft nicht
demonstrieren weil er im Zweifelsfall
Rettungswagen oder die Feuerwehr
blockiert also man darf jetzt nicht so
weit gehen und das Ganze also bis zum
geht nicht mehr der ultimativen
Sicherheit denken weil dann finden
überhaupt keine Demonstrationen irgendwo
in der Stadt man könnte aber bestimmte
Mittel von Demonstranten wie das
Festkleben zum Beispiel sagen das könnte
nicht machen
ist die das zu radikal wie das da gerade
passiert ich meine der Punkt ist ja und
deswegen ist es ja so interessant auch
mit jemandem wie Dir was zivilen
Ungehorsam Macht zu sprechen also wir
sind ja so eine
ich sag mal wir sind ja so eine so eine
so eine Generation also speziell auch
meine Generation wir sind ja schon auf
eine Art und Weise das würde ich uns
schon so ins Klassenbuch schreiben sehr
angepasst wir waren im Wesentlichen mit
mit der Herstellung von Karriere
beschäftigt ja und haben ansonsten uns
so durchgewühlt und stehen jetzt vor
allem ziemlichen stammassel und jetzt
erleben wir wie diese jungen Leute etwas
tun was uns weh tut was uns nervt was
uns richtig auf den Keks geht was uns
provoziert ja aber das Ärgerliche ist
dass die sehr sehr positiv bewertete
klima-bewegung jetzt kritischer gesehen
wird das ist genauso wie die RAF die
Linke diskreditiert hat ja das stimmt ja
also das Erbe die RAF ist ja ein Erbe
von 68 ja und danach war das Grunde
genommen die ganze linke Bewegung die
irgendwo meinte man müsste irgendwie die
Bundesrepublik reformieren
revolutionieren verbessern moralischer
machen was auch immer die Ziele waren
die war durch den Terrorismus komplett
zerstört und davon hat sie sich auch
eigentlich bis heute nicht mehr richtig
erholt also das ist die Gefahr die da
drin steht und wenn das passiert dass
wir also die die
klimaaktivisten mit diesem Ruch oder dem
Verdacht ja dass das dass das irgendwie
doch Terroristen sind und so weiter
umgeben dann gute Nacht also das darf
nicht passieren die Geschichte des
zivilen Ungehorsams ist eine lange
Geschichte wann beginnt die ach
wahrscheinlich hat das gegeben solange
es Menschen gibt ja also das ich glaube
das geht wirklich tief zurück bis in die
griechische Antike Prometheus Mia
Prometheus vielleicht also ja also der
Rebell ist ja schon etwas mehr als
zivile Ungehorsam wird aus der den
Menschen das Feuer gebracht hat gegen
den ausdrücklichen Willen von von Zeus
ja also das und dann bestraft wurde das
ist eher so ein Assange Tat gewesen ich
würde dass er damit vergleichen nicht so
sehr mit zivil und ungehorsam aber wobei
auf eine Art schon ne also ich meine der
ist ein die Grenze zwischen Rebellen TUM
und furchtbar bestraft worden von den
Göttern dafür die die genau die
Geschichte hat sich mir so als
Jugendlicher so eingebrannt die der wird
da fressen doch Vögel von seiner Leber
ne das ja ja genau
also es gibt ja zwei solche Fälle
Prometheus ja wo also die Leber
gefressen wird und das andere ist
Tantalus die berühmten Tantalus Quallen
ja und da die die Moral das kriegt immer
essen und und trinken vor die Nase
gesetzt und kommt nicht dran und so
brutal bestrafen die Götter ja aber
eigentlich geht es um Geheimnisverrat
bitte mit dem Feuer wurden die Menschen
ermächtigt ja und das ist das was die
Götter nicht verziehen haben das dadurch
die Menschen wie Götter werden konnten
deswegen sehe ich das nicht so richtig
als zivilen Ungehorsam machen aber das
interessante und zivilen Ungehorsam ist
eben also der der die berühmteste
Schrift ne das ist die von von Henry
David Turo jetzt sind wir in der Mitte
des 19 Jahrhunderts in Amerika und das
der etwas lustige Geschichte
Turo war ein leidenschaftlicher
Bekämpfer der Sklaverei
und er hatte Schulden und beim Start
Steuerschulden und er hat gesagt ich
zahl euch keine Steuern ja weil die eine
sklavenhalter-gesellschaft seid ob das
tatsächlich ganz ganz genau so weiß so
ein bisschen umstritten weil dazu gehört
auch noch dass er den Krieg der USA
gegen Mexiko abgelehnt hat der hat aber
eigentlich erst begonnen nachdem er
schon ziemlich große Steuerschulden
angehäuft hat also man müsste diese
Geschichte mal mit der Lupe betrachten
auf jeden Fall wurde er bei ein
leidenschaftlicher Verfechter des
zivilen Ungehorsams was er gesagt hat
also es gibt eine Moral ja die die
wichtiger und höher ist als die Pflicht
die ich gegenüber dem Staat habe und das
ist quasi die rechtfertigungsschrift für
zivilen Ungehorsam bis heute also nach
dem Motto der Mensch ist erst seinem
Gewissen verantwortlich und dann zweiter
Stelle im Staat und siehst du es auch so
ja also ich würde ich würde sagen in
ganz großen und existenziellen Fragen
also es wäre ein Witz wenn jeder seine
steuer-frage zu einer kleinen
persönlichen Gewissens Entscheidung
macht und so aber mein Gewissen sagt mir
also man kann damit mit diesem
Instrument ja nicht leichtfertig umgehen
aber sagen wir auf einer ganz großen
existenziellen Ebene ist der Satz nicht
verkehrt
so und da hast du doch die Verbindung
zur sogenannten letzten Generation ist
es ein Unterschied ob jemand sozusagen
einen Staunen Berufsverkehr verursacht
mit allen dramatischen Konsequenzen die
das haben kann selbst wenn es in diesem
Berliner Fall jetzt nicht so war es kann
ja sein dass es demnächst genauso
Eintritt ja das kann ja passieren ja so
ist es ein Unterschied in der in der
Härte des Protests wenn es um die Frage
geht wofür oder wogegen demonstrierst du
eigentlich wofür kennst du eigentlich
also kämpfe ich gegen eine maskenpflicht
in der U-Bahn und klebe mich im
Berufsverkehr fest oder kämpfe ich weil
du gerade sagst die ganz großen Sachen
und schlicht und ergreifend um die
weiter Existenz der Menschheit Stichwort
Klimaveränderung und das ist deren
Anliegen und deswegen sagen sie müssen
wir auch radikal sein weil ihr hört uns
ja nicht ihr macht ja einfach immer
weiter wie auch der Klimagipfel jetzt in
Ägypten gerade über uns wieder zeigt
also wenn man sich mal anhört Larifari
da die Einlassungen so sind am Ende am
Ende ist es doch eine ganz kleine Frage
am Ende ist es die Frage ob man sich im
öffentlichen Verkehr
ankleben sollte oder nicht also ist
nicht die Sache dass man offensichtlich
aufmerksam macht ja auch mit starken
Mitteln für eine so wichtige Sache wie
den Fortbestand der Menschheit das ist
wirst du ja aber genauso wie ich positiv
bewerten und dann zu überlegen welche
Mittel können geeignet sein und welche
können wegen der mutmaßlichen üblen
Konsequenzen die das haben kann welche
sollte man vielleicht nicht wählen also
am Ende ist es doch eigentlich eine
instrumentelle Frage ja es war nicht nur
moralische Frage ja die moralische große
moralische Frage sich für das richtige
Ziel einzusetzen und die instrumentelle
Frage ist die Frage mache ich das so so
oder mache ich das anders genau und da
muss ich kalkulieren und das müssen wir
ab jetzt machen ja seit dieser
unfallgeschichte einfach mit einbeziehen
ist das das richtige Mittel oder zeitig
die richtige Aktion ja möglicherweise
folgen die keiner gewollt hat und die
vermeidbar gewesen wären ich meine klar
ich ich ahne oder versteht den Gedanken
nur muss man nicht auch sagen Protest
ziviler Ungehorsam
der Verstoß gegen die Regeln der muss
uns wehtun bei uns bewirkt er nichts
also ein Protest am Samstagabend gegen
23 Uhr irgendwo am Stadtrand verträumt
am stattfindet richtig hat hat überhaupt
keine Konsequenz das ist so so Walter
Willen Weber schreibt das in seiner
Titelgeschichte da im Stern das ist so
von der von der Wirkung her so wie
bachblütentee ja passiert absolut man
erinnere an die Fridays for future
Geschichte als das losging ja hat man
ganz viel gehört von Politikern
Christian Lindner hat das gesagt ja ist
ja alles gut und schön wichtiges Ziel ja
aber doch nicht während der Schulzeit
das kann man doch schön am Nachmittag
machen nach der Schule und so ja dann
tut es kein weder dann fällt es keinem
auf dann ist es einfach eine schöne ist
bachblütenteeaktion so nur dadurch dass
es mit Schulschwänzen verbunden war hat
es überhaupt die Aufmerksamkeit gekriegt
nur dieses Schulschwänzen führt jetzt
nicht dazu dass mutmaßlich Leute im
Verkehr ums Leben kommen das ist eben
das was man sich überlegen muss also man
muss irgendwo dahin gehen wo es weh tut
aber weh tun im übertragenen Sinn und
nicht im wirklichen konkreten ich meine
wenn man da mal so in die Vergangenheit
guckt da hat ja ziviler Ungehorsam immer
wieder auch sozusagen Dinge adressiert
die viel klarer und viel genauer
adressiert waren deswegen bin ich da
auch bei dir wenn du sagst Kartoffelbrei
auf monaise ist albern ja
ankleben im Berufsverkehr da geht es
natürlich genau unmittelbar um die
Kausalität ja also was verursacht CO2
und wo gesetzten wir da an wenn ja die
größte Idee ja erstmal nachvollziehbar
was dahinter stand dass er die Idee ist
nicht albern
so wenn Du Dir mal die großen Proteste
in den 80er von Greenpeace anguckst
diese Boote ja diese kleinen
Schlauchboote die die gegen irgendwelche
Öltanker dann da an oder diese erinnerst
du dich an diese Tanker von Cornus Titan
den der Nordsee haben die immer
Dünnsäure verklappt tonnenweise
hochgiftiges Zeug ja Dünnsäure verklappt
89 wurde das verboten also das hatte an
den Effekt aber das war auch klar
adressiert da war sozusagen dieser Kampf
David gegen Goliat es war klar da sind
diese Schiffe die haben sich nicht im
Berufsverkehr irgendwo angeklebt die
haben nicht irgendwelche Botschaften
beschmiert oder oder Kunstwerke
beschädigt sondern die sind
herausgefahren haben sich genau dem
exakt demgestellt ist ein Unterschied
deswegen ist ja die Geschichte des
zivilen Ungehorsams so interessant aber
auch diese diese juristische Konsequenz
vielleicht können wir da gleich noch mal
tiefer einsteigen du warst vorhin bei
Toro Richard gibt doch noch andere
berühmte Beispiele für zivilen
Ungehorsam jeder kennt die Gandhi
Geschichte
die Eltern erinnern sich noch
gucke zu dir
ja das das hat das war das Ende des
Kolonialismus ja also es war der der
lange Weg des Ausstiegs in den in den
für das Kolonialismus und dann kann die
gilt natürlich erklären was da war
ja so grundsätzlich also Indien war
englische Kolonie und ehrlich gesagt
wenn man mal sich die Todeszahlen
anguckt und die Verbrechen die die
Engländer in Indien begangen hat das ist
eine der wichtigsten beleuchteten shower
Kapitel das Jahrhundert ja wirklich und
dann dies Weg war ja eben nicht in Form
von unausgesetzten kämpften Rebellionen
oder Sabotageakten was ja viele gemacht
haben in ihnen gegen die Besatz
hervorzugehen eben sondern in Form des
zivilen Ungehorsams ja also der der
kollektiven Arbeitsverweigerung nicht
mitmachen soll und der ist ja mit diesem
Weg erstaunlicherweise eben erfolgreich
gewesen das ist deswegen so spektakulär
weil es so selten vorkommt es gibt nicht
viele Beispiele wo sie wieder Ungehorsam
so mächtig geworden ist
ganz indirekte Art und Weise in
Spurenelementen vielleicht in der DDR ja
also der Zusammenbruch war ja nur eben
auch diese friedliche Revolution war ja
eben auch keine der bewaffneten
Rebellionen ja sondern so dieses Gefühl
die Regierung verliert ihr Erfolg so
dass wir ja eigentlich in unserer
Geschichte mit zivilen Ungehorsam sehr
viel positive Erfahrungen gemacht ich
war übrigens auch mal ganz indirekt
dabei da ich ja zu dieser Generation
Friedensbewegung und so weiter gehöre
haben wir so Menschenketten auf
Autobahnen
also das war gar nicht weit wenn ich das
heute noch wüsste also ich bin ja in
Solingen aufgewachsen das war irgendwo
Nordrhein-Westfalen und ich meine es
wäre eine Osteraktion gewesen und da
ging es darum eine Menschenkette zu
bilden die entlang der gesamten Autobahn
das hat nicht so ganz funktioniert und
ich weiß die Risse immer wieder ein
bisschen ab und so aber so fast
funktioniert das war jetzt innerhalb
dieser Sache jetzt nicht die größte und
spektakulärste Aktion auch nicht die an
die sich alle noch erinnern und ich weiß
gar nicht wie wie legal da weil
natürlich an diesem Sonntag ja
eigentlich Autos davor und die konnten
dann dann natürlich nicht fahren also
das glaube ich nicht dass die Polizei
die Straßen abgesperrt hat damit das
sein kann sondern da musste man sich
eben damit abfinden dass man nicht Auto
fahren kann weil es diese Menschenkette
gibt spektakuläre und berühmter da war
ich nicht dabei ist diese sind diese
Sitzblockaden gewesen da waren Leute wie
Heinrich Bölle glaube ich sogar
Beteiligung Rudolf schaping die haben
die Zufahrtsstraßen zu den
atomraketendepots der Amerikaner in
Mutlangen blockiert damit ihr da nicht
durchfahren konnten oder es gab es auch
später bei den Castor 20 sagen gab es
das ja auch kannst du ja Behälter Spur
dann im Schritttempo durch Deutschland
ja genau weil überall eben die Leute auf
der Straße waren oder die Bahnen
Schienen blockiert haben muss das
getragen werden und sowas alles so es
gibt ja eine lange Tradition dieses
zivilen Ungehorsams aber weißt du was
mich gerade beschäftigt aufgrund des
Einstiegs was am Anfang gesagt hast ne
damals war das nicht so eine riesen
Aufreger ja also zivile Ungehorsam
gehörte würde ich sagen in den 70er 80er
Jahren irgendwie auch dazu und hatte
eine ganz andere Dimension ja wie lange
haben wir aber bei uns inzwischen keinen
mehr gehabt und das meinte ich doch
deswegen wirkt ziviler Ungehorsam heute
viel ungeheuerlicher als es das über
sehr lange Zeit gewesen das war das
meine ich ja ich glaube wir leben
ohnehin in einer Gesellschaft wo diese
Haltung nicht aus der Norm zu fallen ja
nicht nicht verhaltensauffällig zu
werden um keinen Shitstorm zu kassieren
um sich nicht angreifbar zu machen das
hat ja sehr sehr stark zugenommen
gegenüber früher ja ich meine wenn du
wenn du mal also ja hast du Recht die
und du merkst auch wie jeder das
sozusagen auch dann sich nimmt um dann
seine eigene Agenda abzuarbeiten
Dobrindt haben wir schon erwähnt ja
gibt es viele Wege dazwischen ich fand
sehr souverän wie der Kanzler damit
umgeht und und du merkst das kommt ja
aus einer Haltung heraus also zu sagen
Leute ich habe nichts gegen Proteste
weil wir als Demokratie diese Form von
von von
Öffentlichkeit auch brauchen ja aber sag
mal ein bisschen kreativer lasst euch
mal was anderes einfallen ist man könnte
man auch sagen ist so ein bisschen von
oben herab so nach dem Motto so
paternalistisch eine Papa klopft die
immer ganz kurz so ein bisschen offen
streichelt die über Kopf und sagt kommen
jetzt
die Aktionen Kartoffelbrei infantil sind
dann muss man auch damit rechnen wie ein
Kind behandelt so so ganz genau aber
grundsätzlich dieser dieser zivile
Ungehorsam weißt du welche Geschichte
mir wie neulich irgendwie abends beim
Vorlesen stießen wir darauf Rosa Parks
die Frau im Bus genau ja die Geschichte
hat mich wahnsinnig berührt und ich ich
hatte den Namen vorher schon mal gehört
weiter aber man kennt Martin Luther King
und man kennt Gandhi und all diese Leute
und man kennt die weiße Rose und so aber
man kennt nicht unbedingt Rosa Parks
Südstaaten Alabama
eine Afroamerikanerin eine schwarze die
im Bus fährt und sich weigert nach
Aufforderung durch den Busfahrer
aufzustehen um für einen weißen
fahrgastplatz zu machen
eine Wahnsinnsgeschichte und das war
sozusagen die Initialzündung für Martin
Luther King einen Jungen Aktivisten
namens Martin Luther damals kann
erkannte und der dann diese diese
busaktion im Montgomery in Alabama ins
Leben gerufen hat ich habe mir das noch
mal angeguckt 381 Tage hat er zum
Boykott der Busse im [ __ ] Maria
aufgerufen und zwar so lange bis die
Busgesellschaften irgendwann eingeknickt
sind und gesagt haben okay das können
wir so nicht mehr machen weil der
wirtschaftliche Schaden so groß wurde
dass sie schlicht und ergreifend in die
Knie gegangen sind ist eine irre
Geschichte mich Wahnsinns berührt
wahnsinnig berührt was ist die Aktion
zivilen Ungehorsams von der du sagen
würdest dass das hat mich geprägt das
geht mir nahe das ist das was ich im
Kopf habe wenn ich an zivilen Ungehorsam
denke ja vielleicht habe ich so die
Leute die die im Dritten Reich
Widerstand geleistet haben du hast die
weiße Rose erwähnt das ist ja Ziele
Ungehorsam häufig gewesen indem man
militärische Infrastruktur oder
Infrastruktur unter Einsatz seines
Lebens zerstört hat
das was waren ja häufig so
Arbeiterkinder und sowas die das gemacht
haben wir denken beim beim Widerstand an
gern an Staufenberg oder so das glaube
ich auch diesen ganz Kleinen wieder in
der nicht von großen Militärs gemacht
wurde oder so sondern die erleben
riskiert haben Munitionslager hochgejagt
haben und so weiter oben den Krieg zu
verkürzen
das sind so Geschichten gewesen die mich
meiner Kindheit und Jugend stark geprägt
haben
ja ich meine diese dieser Satz habe ich
schon mal erwähnt mein Sohn der mir
immer mal sagte Papa Menschen die an der
richtigen Stelle für eine gute Sache die
Regeln brechen sind das Juwelen
Gesellschaft ja das ist wahr und das
Spannende ist immer sich die Frage zu
stellen warum gibt es Menschen die das
tatsächlich tun er war der
Konformitätsdruck ist wahnsinnig hoch
und für mich ein faszinierendes Bild
zivilen Ungehorsams ist etwa Snowden
[Musik]
also hinzugehen und ohne dass er
irgendetwas davon hatte sondern im
Gegenteil ja Leute danach war ihm völlig
klar er wird ein sehr sehr schwieriges
Leben haben wenn er überhaupt alt wird
und dann hinzugehen und so sagen ja aber
was wir hier machen das geht nicht und
das muss die Öffentlichkeit erfahren
weil das ist schon unglaubliche
Heldentat ihre ich habe mich so oft
gefragt Edwards Noten warum macht er das
ja und das war so jemand der unauffällig
ist ja der der kein Nazis ist eine
starker Narzissen zu sichern großer
Unterschied aber etwas Norden ist der
ganz nette Junge von nebenan total das
hat mich zutiefst beeindruckt um mich
beeindruckend natürlich auch die
nawalnis dieser Welt ja und all diese
Leute die die ihr Leben riskieren oder
dein Sibirien da im Arbeitslager
schmachten für die Sachen die sie für
richtig haben und die keine Verbrechen
begangen haben ja und die wissen dass
der dass der Unrechtsstaat mit aller
Härte gegen sie zuschläkeln ist aber
trotzdem tun die die Journalistin im
Iran die als erste über die junge Kurden
berichtet hat ja
die
totgeprügelt worden ist offensichtlich
weil sie ihren nicht richtig getragen
hat auch diene sitzen das ist dann alle
im Knast und die wissen was sie
riskieren ja und die Idee geht doch noch
die Gefahr an dass die Angehörigen alle
in Sippenhaft genommen werden und so
weiter und so weiter und das musst du ja
auch vor deinem Gewissen dann
verantwortlich und das ist dann trotzdem
Menschen gibt die trotzdem sagen ich
muss das tun ich weiß nicht wie viele
unter 1000 das sind ja also das es wird
doch noch nie rausfinden ja aber das ist
in der Tat der hochbeeindruckend ja ich
also nur kleiner Exkurs sozusagen weil
du gerade auch das Dritte Reich das
sogenannte angesprochen hast
ich meine ich frage mich ganz oft ne
wenn wir heute so kommen und sagen wie
viel konntet ihr nur was habt ihr da
bloß gemacht ich weiß nicht wie wir uns
verhalten hätten weil da drin gewesen
wären ziviler Ungehorsam ich weiß nicht
ob ich mich das getraut hätte also wenn
man das ganz realistisch betrachtet wäre
ich ins Exil gegangen
mich wäre nicht derjenige gewesen der
nachts Eisenbahngleise gesprengt hätte
oder Munitionslager hätte hochgehen
lassen sondern ich hätte gedacht ich
muss das tun was ich am besten kann als
Ausland gehen ja und versuchen mit
Texten einzuwirken aber ein solcher Held
wie diese Leute über die wir gerade
gesprochen haben wäre ich nicht das weiß
ich auch ganz genau und es ist so viel
leichter dann erstmal in die Schweiz zu
gehen ja und und Texte gegen die Nazis
zu verfassen und so weiter als
tatsächlich
sein Leben auf die Art und Weise zu
riskieren also ich glaube da würden
viele Leute ihren Helden gut gigantisch
überschätzen wenn sie tatsächlich in der
Situation sind werden die allerwenigsten
zum Helden
das glaube ich auch und man sollte es
ihn auch nicht vorwerfen dass der
entscheidende Punkt ja man kann es nicht
vorwerfen weil 99 Prozent und noch mehr
der Menschen ja auch so sind und dieser
Gedanke sich anzupassen ich meine unser
Leben besteht ja sehr weitgehend daran
dass wir uns Umständen anpassen um
innerhalb dieser Umstände gut durchs
Leben zu kommen und jemand der hingeht
und alles aufs Spiel setzt alles
riskiert nicht nur sein Leben dass seine
Angehörigen das ist schon irgendeine
ganz spezielle psychische Disposition
und ich weiß nicht ob die gut erforscht
ist aber es wäre interessant total
deswegen glaube ich sind vielfach auch
Menschen genervt von diesem moralischen
Absolutheitsanspruch einer Greta
Thunberg zum Beispiel eine hau dare you
wie könnte es wagen ja wie ich habe
dieser Tag ein interessantes Interview
mit einer jungen Aktivistin
klimaaktivistin aus Marokko gelesen
marokko ist ein unglaublich
faszinierendes Land in dem Zusammenhang
bis 2030 werden die über
50%. das kompletten Energiebedarfs aus
in dem Fall Sonne ja Photovoltaik gener
das ist eine riesen Erfolgsgeschichte
ausgerechnet auf dem afrikanischen
Kontinent ja der für auch das so eine
Zahl so die Zahl der Woche für mich
weißt du eigentlich für wie viel Prozent
des CO2-Ausstoßes der gesamte
afrikanische Kontinent verantwortlich
ist extrem wenig schätzen drei vier
Prozent 3%
3% Deutschland 2 ja also fast so viel
wie ganz Afrika ja ja überleg mal 600
Millionen Menschen in Afrika leben nach
wie vor komplett ohne Strom ja die haben
keinen Zugang zu Strom ich glaube die
ganz große spektakuläre Nachricht jetzt
von der Klimakonferenz in Ägypten die
besteht darin dass wir jetzt etwas
endlich machen was wir bislang nie
gemacht haben
nämlich zu sagen dass die die die am
stärksten vom Klimawandel betroffenen
Länder Reparationszahlungen von denen
die das meiste CO2 in die Luftblasen
haben wollen das ist ja eine neue Art zu
denken ja weil wenn wir die tatsächlich
zahlen müssten wenn wir also hingehen
und den den vereinigen den Ländern in
der südlich der Sahara Ländern wie
Somalia zum Beispiel oder Mali oder so
wenn wir den unglaubliche
Milliardenbeträge zahlen müssten ja für
jeden Toten und verhungerten und für die
verdorrten Felder und das alles dann
würde sich unsere ganze Weise zu
produzieren nicht mehr lohnen und wir
können das nur machen weil wir das alles
nicht bereit sind zu tun also den
Schaden den wir anrichten ja den müssen
wir bislang nicht zahlen genau und wenn
wir wissen dass wir den zahlen müssten
dann sehe die Welt komplett anders aus
ja mal abgesehen davon wie schwierig das
pragmatisch wäre dass das durchzusetzen
und zu machen aber wir machen eben deine
faule Rechnung ja und das ist wird im
Augenblick stark
kritisiert und zum ersten Mal also man
merkt dass die dass die stärksten vom
Klimawandel betroffenen Länder ernster
genommen werden ja gesagt haben die das
schon immer aber sie werden endlich
ernst genommen und wir sind ja bei der
Klimafrage inzwischen auf der Ebene des
veränderten Bewusstseins angekommen aber
noch nicht auf der Ebene des veränderten
Handelns das merkst Du ihm auch in so
einem Land wie Marokko das ist ganz
faszinierende Volksgeschichte die haben
irgendwann einfach Plastiktüten verboten
ich weiß nicht ob die das so klar ist
Plastiktüten waren in Marokko das war
weit mehr als einfach nur eine
Plastiktüte der Plastiktüte im Marokko
war Teil sozusagen der der DNA das war
das war Kulturgut was haben die einfach
verboten mit dem Ergebnis das Agadir und
andere plötzlich saubere Strände haben
darüber hat diese junge Aktivistin eben
gesprochen die irgendwann mal mit drei
Leuten fing die an und die sagte wenn
ich das so machen würde wie eure jungen
Klimaschützer wenn ich so wütend wäre
wenn ich wenn ich zum rumschimpfen würde
wie kriter Thunberg und andere dann wird
das bei mir zu Hause nicht gut ankommen
hätte ich sofort meinem Vater und meiner
Mutter das würde sich niemals gefallen
lassen wir haben anderen Angang an viel
optimistischeren
menschenfreundlicheren Zugang das fand
ich sehr interessant aber du gehst zu
hart mit Greta ins Gericht also
dass sie gesagt hat wie könnt ihr es
wagen mir ging es um die Art und Weise
wie Richard mir gings nicht um den
Inhalt ich ich habe die ich habe sie
aber ich meine verteidigt ja aber diese
aber das das junge Mädchen ja ich kann
es nicht der der PR-Profi ja das ist
kein Obama oder sowas mit Charme und
lächeln und so ihre Botschaften
verbringen also da überschätzt du sie
auch dass das glaube ich kann sie nicht
leisten ich glaube das was sie geleistet
hat dadurch dass sie da waren dass sie
getan hat was sie getan hat hat so
vielen positive Konsequenzen in der Welt
dass ich nicht glaube dass wir jetzt zum
Psychogramm ihres Charakters befinden
was wir nicht gut finden ich wie gesagt
es geht es geht nur um diesen um diesen
moralischen Absolutheitsanspruch und um
diesen Sound und was ich was ich worauf
ich hinaus wollte ist was anderes
uns nervt das es geht uns auf den Keks
festgeklebte Aktivisten am Montagmorgen
in Hunderte solche Aktionen überall in
deutschen Städten und gleichzeitig bin
ich mir manchmal nicht sicher ob wir
verstehen wie wertvoll eigentlich die
Tatsache ist dass wir das dürfen dass
wir das können absolut jetzt sagt ihr
eine kleine Geschichte dazu
die Klimakonferenz findet ja gerade in
Ägypten statt seitdem der Sisi da
in Amt und Würden ist
tausende zehntausende Menschen die
einfach in irgendwelchen Erdlöchern
verschwinden
Folter Menschenrechtssituation
katastrophal und in dieser Situation
findet das dort gerade statt was ich
irre fand war ich aber ein junger Inder
war es der wollte die letzten 500
Kilometer zum Austragungsort ja mit mit
so einem proteststilz und in alter
Gandhi Tradition ja einfach da
durchlaufen
großes Plakat in der Hand haben sie
sofort eingebunkert sofort einkassiert
sofort und so ging es vielen vielen
anderen auch bei uns kleben sich
Menschen am Montagmorgen im
Berufsverkehr fest und wer nicht sofort
einkassiert mit einer Ausnahme es gibt
ein in Bayern ein besonderes Gesetz ja
man kann die Leute glaube ich auf
Verdacht hin oder sowas genau ganze
Weile in polizeigewahrsamen die
polizeiaufgabengesetz ist härter als
alles andere was es sonst so in der
Republik gibt und die können präventiv
ist das entscheidende zweimal bis zu 30
Tage kannst du Leute ins Gefängnis
stecken eingeführt 2021 diese
Präventivhaft und wurde der Bevölkerung
vermittelt oder man könnte auch sagen
verkauft mit dem Verweis auf
brandgefährliche islamistische
Attentäter ein bisschen unzeitgemäß ja
also zumindest irgendwie finde ich die
die sozusagen die also die Vermengung
dieser beiden Dinge finde ich irgendwie
schwierig also Protest als sehr
legitimes und auch legales
demokratisches Mittel und andererseits
ja
islamistische Attentäter von denen ich
auch der Meinung bin dass man sie
dringend ins Gefängnis packen sollte das
jetzt so zusammenzubringen und und die
Leute dann notfalls auch zweimal 30 Tage
einzubunkern für die schwierig ja finde
ich auch schwierig
merkwürdig ich habe das gar nicht
mitgekriegt also es ist ja
offensichtlich kein groß skandalisiertes
Thema gewesen aber es lohnt sich da nur
genauer hinzu finde ich ja oder du
liebst jetzt Markus Söder in deine
Sendungen frag sie mal direkt was er
sich dabei gedacht hat ja er ist
interessant und da siehst du aber halt
eben auch und das ist finde ich
interessant dass wir immer wieder uns da
überprüfen und hinterfragen und uns mal
wieder klar machen okay so sehr es uns
nervt so sehr ist Protest und und
nervige Aktionen am Montagmorgen auch
ein Teil ein wichtiger Teil dieser
Demokratie also was ja irgendwie eine
wichtige Quintessenz an der Sache ist
ist das ziviler Ungehorsam etwas ist was
in einem demokratischen Rechtsstaat
möglich sein muss
genauso wie Demonstrationen
Versammlungen und sehr nervige Aktionen
dass das ist alles das was uns
unterscheidet das ist das was uns
ausmacht und worauf wir zu Recht stolz
sind selbst wenn es im praktischen Fall
nervt auf der anderen Seite muss ja
jeder Mensch diesen eigenen moralischen
Ermessensspielraum ja mit einem relativ
hohen Maß an Urteilskraft ausstatten
weil sonst kann es natürlich passieren
wie in der corona-pandemie dass Leute
ganz früh das Gefühl haben dass das was
passiert mit ihrem Gewissen nicht
vereinbar ist zum Beispiel eine Maske zu
tragen da ist das so häufig gefallen ja
und das ist mir nicht ungehorsam ja das
ist mir nicht plausibel zu machen weil
das aus meiner Sicht eben keine
Ungeheuerlichkeit ist die jemand
zugemutet wird und jetzt haben wir das
große Problem das ist natürlich ein
subjektives Ermessen dafür gibt was eine
Ungeheuerlichkeit ist oder was zugemutet
werden kann und was nicht und haben wir
richtig die Schwierigkeit gesehen
zwischen den Heeren Grundsätzen auf der
einen Seite aber das eben auch eine eine
Mündigkeit und eine Urteilsfähigkeit da
sein muss die Verhältnismäßigkeit immer
zu sehen und sich zu sagen ist das ein
Akt wo ich jetzt hier ruhig gegen
rebellieren sollte oder müsste
dann kann Jana aus Kassel was war mit ja
ich erinnere mich nicht
aus Kassel ist ganz ganz berühmte
Geschichte musst du dir bei youtube mal
angucken eine irre Geschichte wo eine
eine corona-leugnerin sieht genau über
die Maßnahmen auf offener Bühne
fürchterliche chauffiert und sagt sie
fühlt sich wie so viel Scholl ja ja das
oh Gott
es ist einfach zu viel du kannst dich
hier nicht hinstellen als
corona-leugnerin und sagen du bist
eigentlich in der Tradition von Sophie
schon unterwegs
aber das Wichtigste was man ja dafür
brauchen sozusagen eine so eine
Urteilsfähigkeit geschulte Menschen
die mit dem Begriff Gewissen
auch wirklich gewissenhaft umgehen genau
und das ist etwas wo ich denke das
gehört zu diesen wichtigen Dingen die
man in seinem Leben und in der Schule
und was weiß ich was viel besser lernen
muss denn am Ende kommt es ja bei allen
Fragen des zivilen Ungehorsams auf das
Prinzip der verhältnismäßig und da sehe
ich natürlich das Thema an Klimawandel
das bei aller Bedeutung immer noch aus
meiner Sicht ein unterschätztes Thema
ist wenn wir uns überhaupt noch gar
nicht ausmalen können ich meine in
Ägypten reden wir ja nicht mehr über das
1,5 Grad Ziel ich weiß dass sie im
Wahlkampf noch die Rede war ja
Deutschland muss das 1,5 Grad Ziel und
so alles dazu beitragen und so weiter
jetzt reden wir von 2,5 Grad das hat
sich schon verschoben und selbst da sind
wir jetzt nicht mehr sicher dass wir das
schaffen also da sind wir in einer
mörderischen Spirale drin ja wir müssen
ständig in unverantwortbare Richtwerte
korrigieren
das ist schon ein unglaubliche
Herausforderung für die die Menschheit
da ich ich finde wir sollten so ein so
ein klima-update demnächst mal machen
Richard das mich viel mit dem Thema
beschäftigt auch in den letzten Wochen
bis der beängstigend fast die Hälfte des
gesamten eu-gebietes ist mittlerweile
Dürre Gebiet trocken extreme Trockenheit
wenn du das so hörst wenn du hörst wie
zum Beispiel rund um Magdeburg ja rund
um Magdeburg ich meine das ist die
Kornkammer Deutschlands da reden ja da
regnet es mittlerweile so wenig dass die
Frage ist was wächst da demnächst noch
und wenn du das mal konsequent zu Ende
denkst kommst du ganz schnell zur Frage
was essen wir denn jetzt eigentlich mal
übermorgen dann was genau ja und wir
können uns die Frage noch stellen was
wir essen die Menschen in Somalia
brauchen sich die Frage nicht verstehen
die haben nichts mehr zu essen genau und
insofern ist die Frage nach der
Verantwortung auch da auch eine mediale
Verantwortung vielleicht ist das ein
gutes Schlusswort Richard du hast ganz
am Anfang über Skandalisierung
gesprochen ne wir regen uns auch ich
rege mich jetzt über Kartoffelbrei auf
nie ganz fürchterlich auf statt froh
darüber zu sein dass es überhaupt noch
Kartoffelbrei gibt aber die die
Geschichte ist natürlich wir
echauffieren uns ganz fürchterlich über
das was da passiert und verlieren
eigentlich das große Thema dabei ganz
häufig aus den Augen das Thema um das
ist wirklich gehen müsste nämlich diese
menschheitsaufgabe vor der wir da stehen
und
ich glaube darüber
sind wir uns doch gar nicht so wirklich
im Klaren was da wirklich auf uns
zukommt ja das ist das ganz große
Problem wenn es sich um Risiken handelt
die nicht sinnlich anschaulich sind ich
meine die Tatsache dass wir jetzt ein
Bewusstseinswandel haben dass die
allermeisten Menschen in Deutschland den
Klimawandel ernst nehmen verdanken wir
den abbrennenden Wäldern und dein
allererster Linie der Flutkatastrophe im
Ahrtal und dabei haben sich viel viel
schrecklichere Katastrophen zugespielt
zugetragen im Zusammenhang mit dem
Klimawandel und jeden Tag ist die für
diese Katastrophe dazu dass in Afrika
tausende von Menschen
das ist die reale Dimension dessen was
wir da tun und
der Bewusstseinswandel alleine reicht
nicht ich habe das vorhin gesagt wir
brauchen nicht nur Bewusstsein sondern
wir brauchen wirklich einen
handlungswandel und das ist das was
tatsächlich die facto nicht passiert ist
und das auch in dem einen Jahr in dem
die Bundesregierung bisher dran ist
nicht merklich vorangekommen ist sondern
unsere bilanzfelder sehr sehr traurig
aus Wahnsinn Richard ich danke die sehr
vielleicht hat die alte Frau auf
Madagaskar richtig neulich im in
Deutschland Funk hörte die sagte auf die
Frage warum es denn so wenig regnet das
hat damit zu tun dass wir Menschen uns
nicht mehr richtig lieb haben ja aber
vielleicht liegt es tatsächlich daran
dass die Menschen in den reichen Ländern
des Westens und des Nordens die Menschen
im Süden nicht gut genug lieb haben so
ist es genau also in diesem Sinne Liebe
und Harmonie wir hören uns wir hören uns
alles gute Idee
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF